IRATE THE SENATE BANKING ON
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BANKING
AND FINANCE INSTITUTIONS WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
IN RESPONSE TO THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NINETY CENTS FOR GATHERINGS AND
IF YOU'RE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED A NUMBER THAT WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT TO DATE
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY THREE AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES DON'T WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED
BY AM HONOR MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WEEK ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
MIND NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THE
TIME YOU WILL BE AND MUTED AND
YOU WALK YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND THAT WE AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING PROCESS OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
ON TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE
ONE BILL AND BEFORE WE HEAR
THE PRESENTATION ON THE BILL
COMMITTEES ESTABLISHED FARM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
LIMON HERE ALONE HERE UNTIL
ABOUT BUT CHAU ABOUT HERE
BRADFORD EASIER BRADFORD
HERE CABALLERO I'LL BE
OUT HERE DALLY YOUR DAILY
HERE THEY'RE ALSO HERE
THE ROUTE SO HERE WESO MEN
YES MEN HERE PORTANTINO
THE CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR AUTHOR WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON YOU MAY
BE REGAINED BY PRESENTING YOUR
BILL AB SEVEN SIX NINE THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR IN THE STEAM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SIXTY NINE WHICH AUTHORIZES
UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TO A CORPORATION TO
CONDUCT ITS ANNUAL SHAREHOLDER
OF SHELL SHAREHOLDER MEETING
REMOTELY GENERALLY CALIFORNIA
LAW REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS MUST HAVE SOME
TYPE OF IN PERSON COMPONENT
TO THEIR ANNUAL MEETINGS BUT
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
THE NEWSOME ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO PROVIDE COMPANIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO CONDUCT THESE
MEETINGS REMOTELY WHILE THE
VIRUS POSES A PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK SO FAR THIS FLEXIBILITY
HAS BEEN A SUCCESS AND REMOTE
SHAREHOLDERS MEETINGS HAVE
LED TO INCREASED PARTICIPATION
UNFORTUNATELY THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT ALLOWS TO FOR
REMOTE SHAREHOLDER MEETINGS
WILL EXPIRE ON MARCH THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO AB
SEVEN SIXTY NINE SIMPLY EXTENDS
THE CURRENT POLICY UNTIL THE
SUMMER WELL WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE PHASING OUT
THE TEMPORARY PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE
JUST THIS MORNING I READ ABOUT
NEW SPIKES IN COVERT NINETEEN
CASES ABROAD WITH THIS IN MIND
IT IS APPROPRIATE THAT WE GRANT
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WHICH WILL
ALLOW SUCH MEETINGS TO BE HELD
SAFELY ULTIMATELY AB SEVEN
SIXTY NINE WILL PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH BY PROVIDING A
SIMPLE EXTENSION OF THE POLICY
THAT HAS ALREADY PROVEN TO BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO
THE CHAIR MY WITNESS TEN COUNTS
FOR REGIONAL VP AT SOMETHING
THANK YOU THE MANAGER MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HEARING THE BILL
TODAY CAN'T CALLOUS ON BEHALF
OF SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC
SOCALGAS AND SEMPRA I WON'T
REPEAT WHAT THE AUTHOR STATED
SUMMED IT UP IT'S REALLY SIMPLE
BILL WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
IN THIS ONE TIME EXTENSION TO
ALLOW US TO HOLD THE REMOTE
MEETING SAFELY OVER THE NEXT
TWO MONTHS AND I QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE A RECOVERY AFTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR KRAUSS NEXT
WE HAVE OUR OUR RUN ACT DAYLAMI
FROM THE CALCHAMBER WHO WILL
TESTIFY BELIEVE OVER THE PHONE
YES CHAIR NUMBER ONE OKAY
LAWMAKER THE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
REPORTED EIGHTY SEVEN SIX NINE
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
IN FURTHERANCE OF PROMOTING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICES
THE BILL PROVIDE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THE INSURANCE THAT THEY
HAVE EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO
COME BACK ABOUT SHAREHOLDER
MEETING FOR THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
FOLLOWING THE EXPIRATION DATE
ON YOUR EXECUTIVE ORDER SHALL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR COMPLIANCE
OF LONGER TERM STABILITY IN
THE COMING EIGHTEEN PANDEMIC
IF THERE'S BEEN ANY RELIABLE
AT HAND AND THAT IT WOULD BE
THE CONSTANT SHIP IN OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA AND INVOLVING
TITLE BUSINESS I PACKAGE --
FINDING THE CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH NEEDS NOT POLITICAL
CARTOONIST MARK THAT WOULD
MAKE CHANGES TO THEIR PRACTICES
ESPECIALLY AS WE TRANSITION
HOPEFULLY INTENT AND GOVERNMENT
APPROACH TO THE CURRENT IRATE
PANDEMIC I ALSO DON'T WANT TO
BE A LONG AND LIKE THEM AND
GIVEN THAT I'M BUT BELT BUT I
WILL JUST SAY WE BELIEVE THAT
THE BILL BE CREATED BY EIGHTY
NINE BOTH EXTREMELY HELPFUL
AND MOST PRUDENT FINANCIAL
PERIOD POLITICS TECHNICAL
ORDER WE ASKED ABOUT I THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU NOW DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER FOLKS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
IMPOSITION ANYONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WE DO PLEASE
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE GOOD
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY JOHNSON ON
BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC
COMPANY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WE WILL MOVE
TO ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WHO ARE
-- ON THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SIX NINE WE WILL BEGIN SURE
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SIX NINE THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE YOU'RE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE
PICK UP YOUR HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEM ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
SIX NINE AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
A GOOD AFTERNOON LONGER PROGRAM
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA EDISON
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SIX NINE ONE ZERO
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN
YOUR MANAGER THANK YOU VERY
MATHIS AT NOW WE WILL HEAR
FROM WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE ANY
STATED OPPOSITION AT THE MOMENT
AND I'M LOOKING AROUND THE
HEARING ROOM TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
MODERATOR AS CAN YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE PHONE LINES TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY
SEVEN SIX NINE ONE ONE BILL
ON YOUR PHONE AND AGAIN AS THE
VISION OF AB SEVEN SIX NINE
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
SHOWING UP AS OF RIGHT NOW
MAN THANK YOU AT SINCE WE HAVE
HEARD OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WE WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION TO MEMBERS MEMBERS
AT SENATOR DALY -- THE BILL
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT WITH C.
NINE AT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND WE WILL THE MOTION IS TO
MOVE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIX
NINE THE MOTION AND SO I WILL
READ ONCE HE PASSES RIGHT
THE REST OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST TO RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WILL
MOUNT I ALONE I BUT CHAU BOAT
WHICH -- BUG HI BRADFORD HI
BRADFORD I CABALLERO W.
L.
I.
DALLI DALLI I THE RUSSELL
HI THE RUSSELL II WESO
MAN MAN HI PORTANTINO
I RATE THEM AT THE BILL HAS
SEVEN -- ICE AND WE WILL PULL
THAT -- ON CALL TO SEE IF ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS JOIN US
-- AND -- THAT IS IT FOR THE
DAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
ONLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND I JUST
REALIZED I DIDN'T GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MEDICARE NETWORK OKAY THANK
YOU IRATE AND WE DO HAVE A
MEMBER HERE TO DO IT ADAM VOTE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
WEST SO LET'S -- I'D
ALL RIGHT THE BILL HAS AYE
EAT AYE VOTES AND THAT BILL
MOVES ON TO JUDICIARY THANK
YOU EVERYONE THIS CONCLUDES
THE SENATE BANKING COMMITTEE